so let's break it apart shall we
terrestrial terrestrial nice terrestrial
wait yeah that's extraterrestrial so so
18 right he's extraterrestrial cause
extra means outside right so terrestrial
actually means ground pests or earth
based okay so the picture looks
something like this here's is the
curvature of the earth okay and what you
can have is all of these towers set up
that don't use radio right where do is
is a multi-directional just goes
everywhere okay
hence and to this kind of diagram just
there has no direction okay but
microwaves are in a certain direction to
try and get to someone who's far away
sending a signal like this okay so
microwaves refers to the fact that it's
a very high-powered kind of signal okay
because microwaves the smaller the
frequency or the higher the frequency
the smaller the wavelength and the
higher the frequency the more energy
that goes into this okay so these
signals can travel tens of kilometers at
a time okay but because they're
directional again just like with
infrared you require line-of-sight okay
and so you're gonna have actually
several of these set up and they have to
be able to see each other okay kinda
look like Christmas trees but anyway to
get the idea all right so these can go
much much larger distances to rescue
microwaves okay lastly we are going to
go extraterrestrial yeah
yeah yeah good so the question of
interference is always an important one
because it's going to muck around with
the signals the answer is anything
anything gets in the way anything that
you know sources of radiation that are
in between here okay and so you've got
two things number one that's why these
signals are so high-powered because if
you can imagine this compare a
high-power signal to like someone is
shouting really really that okay if I'm
shouting really really loud at you you
would have to introduce some very very
loud interference to get over my signal
does that make sense okay
so the higher power this signal is the
higher power the interference also has
to be to actually change what's being
received secondly terrestrial microwave
like we associate if I'm talking to you
I'm having a conversation with you I say
something once and you like okay sure
but if you get it you're like oh wait
what did you say and she asked for
clarification but under this system
things are frequently set just multiple
times okay a signal that we set ten
times okay and when you look at it
you're like five of them are different
but five of them are the same and that's
how you know that's the one that you
actually want okay so these are just
ways of avoiding errors or trying to
make sure you you actually get the right
signal arriving okay
so interference happens all the time
that's the big thing with wireless
actually that anything can creep in and
muck around the signals less chance
compared to what that's right that's
right
which is why though in reality you know
for instance I said infrared
line-of-sight less than 10 meters okay
in reality it's much much much less than
10 minutes because there's all kinds of
other infrared things that can get in
the way like you know my hand or your
body won't anything like that right so
yeah the lower power 2d is that the less
far it's going to go